NARRATOR: In South Carolina,
a century-old sawmill
stands between Eustace
and a much needed bonus
payday worth
thousands of dollars.
The dang thing's
going backwards.
Oh man, that ain't good.
NARRATOR: But he
and Joseph have hit
a new snag with the saw blade.
Yeah, the saw will fly off.
Oh my gosh.
We gotta get this
thing turned around.
NARRATOR: To shift the
blade in the forward motion,
Eustace eases the
transmission into first gear.
I'm glad we caught that.
You ready again?
Yeah.
OK.
Here we go.
Rev it up a little bit.
Yeah.
It seems like it's
going to work.
I mean, it's going fast enough
that it at least looks it.
We just got to try it out now.
JOSEPH: That throttle enough?
Yeah, go ahead
and speed it up.
Let's see what we can do.
JOSEPH: All right.
EUSTACE: So far
it's working well.
The more we saw, the
more I can kind of
figure out and develop
a little confidence
in how this thing works.
And Joseph's getting
his job done well.
We get into quite a rhythm here.
NARRATOR: Eustace and
Joseph's quick fix
of the old-time sawmill
isn't holding up.
EUSTACE: We have to
shut the mill off
before it burns something
up, tears something up.
We have a major problem here.
That is scary.
JOSEPH: Well it just
wasn't going that fast.
NARRATOR: Their goal
is to get the mill
working well enough
to cut boards
from the trees they've felled.
If he can't cut
the lumber, he'll
have to leave thousands
of dollars on the ground,
at the moment he needs it most.
What happened is the blade
got lodged in the wood.
And so, the motor's
smoking because that power
is being delivered.
But it couldn't go anywhere.
The saw could not
turn, dislodged in the
would like that.
Basically, you got
too much pressure on it.
Maybe it's too dull.
JOSEPH: You couldn't turn it.
Yeah.
I just think we got
to sharpen that saw.
There's just too
much for resistance.
This thing been sitting out
20 or 30 years, you know.
Yeah.
We'll just take a
minute and sharpen it.
All right.
It's important to dig in
the bottom of the tooth.
The good thing is
they're all still here.
We didn't lose one in the log.
JOSEPH: Yeah, that is good.
- Yeah.
Looks like this is the
one we're looking for,
this last one.
Let's see if we can
get this thing going.
EUSTACE: It's amazing to see
this old mill actually work.
With the power
units working good,
the mill's cutting straight.
Looks like we're going to be
able to make this thing happen.
Every time we get another
board coming off this mill,
I feel like we're
one step closer
to buying that land back home.
Well all right,
let's get back to it.
JOSEPH: All right, man.
Sounds good.